الى حكومه تصريف الاعمال الاسرائيليه التي
عقدت اجتماعها الاسبوعيه بينما
يوصلته مع قاره الاحزاب لتشكيل حكومته
على الحدود مع لبنان وسوريا تستمر حتى يوم
الخميس
ومعنى الان من امام مقر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في القدس مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري اهلا بك وليد اذا ماذا في
تفاصيل المشاورات والمناورات اليوم
المشاورات حتى الان لم تحرز التقدم الذي
يريده نتنياهو صحيح انه توصل الى ابرام
اتفاق اولي مع عقائد
زعيم ما يعرف بالصهيونيه الدينيه واحد
زعماءها لكن هو يواجه صعوبات مع الزعيم
الاخر وهو اسمه
هذا يطالبوا بصلاحيات اضافيه على الوزارات
التي يريدها ويبدو ان الموضوع غايه في
الصعوبه من هنا المساله همم مساله
المشاورات يبدو انها ستمتد هذا الاسبوع
ايضا نتنياه ما زال امامه اربعه عشر يوما
في هذه المهله تنتهي ليس لاحد المقبل
وانما الاحد الذي يليه ومن بعدها يستطيع
الحصول على مهله اضافيه لكن المؤشرات انه
في نهايه المطاف سيصل الى الى هذه الحكومه
الاحتلافيه التي ستتشكل مركباتها من اقصى
من المتطرف في اسرائيل والذين يرفعون
شعارات معاديه للعرب اما على الصعيد
المناورات التي بدات اليوم على الحدود مع
لبنان وسوريا الناطق باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انها ضمن الخطه السنويه
للمناورات لكنها ستستمر حتى يوم الخميس
وهي عباره عن مناورات مشتركه لقوات جويه
وبريه وهدفها التعامل مع كافه الاحتمالات
همم
المفاجئه منها او ما هو منظور
ستتواصل وتتعامل وتحاكي ايضا حربا
ومواجهها على عده جبهاته في المنطقه
الشماليه المتخمه للحدود مع لبنان وكذلك
مع سوريا وايضا الهدف منها حسب تعبيره هي
الوقوف على الجاهزيه القتاليه والحربيه
للجيش الاسرائيلي ولقواته المنتشره على
طول هذه الحدود واضح بانه اذا ما ان
المناورات واخذنا المشاورات ان الامرين
يسيران في اتجاه تقريبا يدل على حاله
التوتر وربما التوتير التي تشهدها اسرائيل
سواء بسبب الاوضاع في المنطقه او داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه او الحكومه التي يعطف
نتنياهو على تشغيلها والتي توصف بانها
ستكون الاكثر عنصريه
وتطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل بحكم مركباتها
التي تتوعد الفلسطينيين وتتوعد العرب في
داخل الخط الاخضر كذلك وتتوعد القدس وهناك
من يهدد من
قادته اليمين المتطرف فيها بانه سيعمل على
السماح لليهود بممارسته شعائرهم وطقوسهم
بالكامل في الاقصى وهناك مجموعات ضمن
الصهيونيه الدينيه التي تتشكل من ثلاثه
مركبات وهي عباره عن حركات عنصريه مغاليه
في تطرفها والتي تدعو هناك مركبات بينها
تدعو ليس الى ضم مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه واجزاء من الضفه الغربيه والتشريع
ابو ارين الاستيطانيه
وانما ايضا لمحاوله همم تخطط من اجل اقامه
ما يسمونه بالهيكل مكان المسجد الاقصى لذا
مساء مساله التوتير في هذه الحكومه اذا ما
قيد لها ان تتبلور وتبدا عملها وكذلك
المناورات تشير الى ان المنطقه على الاغلب
مقبله على مزيدا من التوتر